president Trump's upcoming meeting with
his Chinese counterpart could be a lot
more contentious than either one of them
has planned that's partially because of
increasing tension between the US and
China over trade chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge tells
us tonight national security is also
becoming a major issue in the
relationship for the first time in 25
years the asia-pacific summit ended
without a formal joint statement among
the 21 leaders China was apparently the
holdout over trade disagreements in the
president's words China's taken
advantage of the United States for many
many years and those days are over
the Chinese president addressed the
strategic dilemma mankind has once again
reached a crossroads which direction
should we choose cooperation or
confrontation after the us-china clash
at APEC attention is focused on the
upcoming g20 summit next week in
Argentina where presidents Trump and G
are expected to meet recently signing
cybersecurity legislation the president
laid down a marker China wants to make a
deal they sent a list of things that
they're willing to do which was a large
list just not acceptable to China in my
opinion is the biggest national security
threat long-term this country will ever
face the number one number two and
number three priority when it comes to
intelligence gathering is America when
it comes to China Bob Anderson a former
executive assistant FBI director
specialized in hacking spying and
economic espionage he said the bureau is
badly outnumbered by China's Ministry of
State Security think of it as they're
FBI without any rules if there's thirty
five thousand men and women in the FBI
there's 400,000 and the MSS in October
the Justice Department indicted a member
of the MSS for allegedly targeting US
aerospace and aviation technology
earlier this month the department took
the unusual step of singling out a
Chinese state-owned company after a 20
month investigation the FBI now has
Chinese economic espionage cases in
almost all 50 states well it's hard to
quantify the economic cost this
independent commission on intellectual
property theft found
damage could run as high as 600 billion
annually Anderson said it doesn't stop
there
specifically with China and Russia
there's been alliances between them you
have to look at that with a wary eye
because when you put two countries of
that magnitude with the amount of
intelligence organizations that they
have against our country it's
unbelievably significant in response the
Chinese embassy provided Fox News with a
70 page document that alleges the
current US administration stigmatizes
China by accusing it of intellectual
property thefts adding the allegations
are a quote gross distortion of the
facts Mike Catherine Herridge here in
Washington Catherine thank you